know how many income sources you have  well let's see we have beef burger Pizza  bowls we have a company where we dub  channels which runs our Mr Visa espanol  and we do that for other people we have  Mr Beast Mr Beast gaming Beast react  merch honestly I'd have to like open my  bank account look through it we built  this app we had people put their finger  on the outside what would you say your  main source of income is if you're to  pick one thing yeah Feast Burger has  done over 100 million in sales and  obviously that number's grown a lot  bigger since then because it's something  people can repeatedly buy like a burger  can order multiple times a week merch is  only going to buy like twice a year what  about sponsorships yeah those have  gotten crazy recently